[music]
>> Some people are still filtering into the
room.
But it's mostly intro stuff for the
first couple of slides so they won't
miss anything. Okay, welcome everybody.
My name is Brendan. I'm I'm a research
scientist at DeepMind. I'm talking today
about text diffusion, which is kind of a
more forward-looking research area at
DeepMind. So you're probably familiar
with image and video diffusion, which is
kind of state of the art for these
modalities right now where you you know,
you take ground truth, say image, you
add noise to it in training, and then
you train a neural network to remove
that noise gradually, and then at
inference time you just initialize
the the picture with pure noise, and
then you iteratively refine out the
noise to recover back to, you know,
whatever image or video or audio or
whatever you're looking for. And the
principle is essentially the same for
text for text diffusion, where you start
with a clean
sequence of tokens, like so a clean
sentence or something like that. And
then you gradually add noise, you
corrupt it somehow. There's lots of
different ways to do that. You can do it
in continuous or discrete way, but let's
just say discrete for now, which would
in this case just mean adding random
tokens or replacing tokens with other
random tokens. And you do that for a
bunch of different noise levels, and you
train the neural network to try to fill
in to try to correct the mistakes
basically in the text. And then at
inference time you initialize the
sequence of tokens to just pure noise,
like pure random discrete tokens from
the vocabulary, and then you iteratively
refine through that to fill in the
information in the order that the neural
network wants to do to recover back to,
say, a clean sentence.
And then in practice, so we, you know, I
showed we I showed you some GIFs here of
what it looks like for images. You get
very similar looking at for text, where
it kind of uh
you know, starts off all noisy and then
gradually like fills in the text and
then you get clean relatively clean
outputs at the end.
Okay, so the the team I'm on we had a a
research demo release 1 year ago now
called Gemini diffusion which was a
variant of a Gemini model which did text
diffusion instead of auto aggressive
next token generation and that was like
a research preview that was open to
about 100k people.
Uh
>> [clears throat]
>> And you know, we're still you know, keep
keep posted for new new developments in
that direction
upcoming soon.
Um And we did have some good numbers at
the time, but again it's a year ago
which is like you know, prehistoric
times in this field. Our kind of main
competitor model was Gemini 2.0
flashlight at the time cuz that was the
architecture we were branching from the
text fusion model and we basically had
very similar quality across the board
there. Um mostly you know, a little bit
of advantage in code, a little bit of
disadvantage in some other areas, but
kind of relatively similar performance
at much better latencies.
Um but again yeah, this is a year ago so
I wouldn't fixate too much on these
numbers.
Okay, so what's the difference between
auto aggressive generation and
diffusion? So in in the standard vanilla
Gemini Gemma you know, GPT whatever
um generation of text you do this you
know, you have some context that comes
in and you want to generate some
response to that and the model does it
one token at a time. So it generates the
first token and then condition on that
generates the next token and so on.
Whereas in diffusion you have the you
know, a context will come in whatever
that is and it'll initialize like I like
I mentioned like a long sequence of
tokens could be hundreds could be
thousands could be shorter depends on
the model uh to be random noise and then
it iteratively refines that canvas to
remove the noise over the course of a
few denoising steps. So rather than one
token at a time it does the entire block
together but over a couple of
iterations. So it's not just one pass,
it does multiple passes, but it gets to
attend to the future tokens and so on.
So, it's a kind of a different way of
generating text. Uh um
So, that obviously has some pros and
cons. So, the main pro that people
really like and probably is the biggest
advantage that text-to-image models have
is that it's it's just faster inference.
It just generates faster tokens per
second cuz it makes much better use of
the hardware, the TPU and the GPU. And I
have some slides on that to explain why.
Um but some other advantages are it can
do bidirectional attention within the
within this canvas of tokens. So, you
know,
autoregressive models can only attend to
the past. They have causal attention
within their, you know, their
transformer. Whereas the a text-to-image
model is not restricted at all. It can
attend to the future. And that has some
interesting properties like it can do
self-correcting generation based on
future tokens. So, it could like, you
know, do some reasoning, see that it got
the answer incorrect, and then go back
and fix the reasoning and do it again. I
have I have a demo of that.
Um because this this process is is
iterative, it does a number of steps to
to to respond, and that means the model
can actually do adaptive computation. It
it it turns out that you can train the
model to spend more time on harder
problems and less time on easier
problems. And like like the fusion
models in general, you can do things
like in-place editing where you say like
fix the last tokens and give me the
prefix that corresponds to those tokens
and stuff.
Um but the main disadvantage it has and
the reason why it's not kind of used
everywhere right now is lower throughput
for large batches. So,
autoregressive models, they're slow, but
you can have a big batch of queries
together, and then if you push that
through the neural network through on
the GPU, each individual user is slow,
but that you make good use of the TPU by
doing that. And so, you can serve a lot
of queries. And so, you keep your costs
down. You can serve a lot. Whereas since
text-to-image does multiple forward
passes on the same data, it, you know,
it hits a compute threshold basically
earlier, and it's it's even though it's
lower latency for any one user, it tends
to be, you know, lower throughput
overall. So, higher cost to serve. And
right now, you know, if you have if
you've played with Claude recently, uh
you'll know that they have some
throughput concerns. So, uh
people really care about throughput
right now. And so, no one's landing text
diffusion into any of these big models
primarily because of that disadvantage.
It's just too expensive to serve, even
if it is much lower latency.
Okay, so just leading into why does it
have lower latency in case you're not
familiar with kind of the architecture
of how GPUs and TPUs run today. So, in a
in a GPU, there's like a a tensor core,
which does these like big matrix
multiplies. It's very efficient, has a
lot of flops or hops or, you know,
whatever.
Uh and then the memory that sits on the
TPU GPU, this this HBM, that's where the
weights and the activations and
everything are stored, and that has to
transfer over
from the memory, all the weights and the
activations and the KV cache, into the
tensor core in order to do the
computation. And so, it has to flow
through this bandwidth channel. And that
bandwidth channel is very tight.
It turns out that the the both GPUs and
TPUs have a lot of flops and not that
much bandwidth. It's quite hard to It's
expensive to put bandwidth onto these
chips, and it's easy to put flops. So,
because of that ratio, you can uh you
you know, you can If you do the more
flops you do for each streaming amount
of data you put through, the better. All
right, so
So,
when we're serving uh an auto regressive
model, these these chips are memory
bound. They're basically
bottlenecked by this bandwidth.
Um so, when you do auto regressive next
token generation, for each token, you're
doing one token at a time. Let's say
batch size one.
You have to stream over the entire
neural network and all the KV cache and
everything to get one token,
and then you do it again for the next
token and so on.
Whereas for text diffusion, you're
generating, say, 256 tokens, you still
will over everything, but if you can do
that less times
than the number of tokens, this
iterative refinement process, then
you'll get a speed up. So, if you can
do, say, 24 passes to generate 256
tokens, you'll be doing
10 times fewer memory transfers than an
autoregressive model. And if you are
truly memory bound, then you'll be 10
times faster, something like that. So,
that's that's the real reason, that's
the hardware reason why uh text-to-image
models are much lower latency than
autoregressive models. Okay.
So, you know, we had this Gemini
diffusion demo.
Maybe some of you got access to it uh
last year. And, you know, that was able
to hit, you know, something like 2,000
tokens a second
um pretty consistently, depending on the
length of the query. Obviously, it
depends. The longer sequence it's
generating, the less it's prefill
dominated. And so, you can really lean
into these very long sequences of very
fast tokens. But, if you're only
generating one token, for instance,
you'll be just dominated by the cost of
the prefill. And the tokens per second
number that was reported on this webpage
was incorporated prefill and everything
like that.
So, this was 2,000 tokens a second.
Those were genuine raw tokens that you
would receive in your web browser.
Okay, so that was the
kind of a whirlwind tour of
text-to-image and its main advantage,
which is latency. But, I want to dig in
a little bit into some of the other
advantages that text-to-image has, which
are kind of a little bit less talked
about in the literature.
Um but, I think are pretty cool, and
this is why I'm excited about it. So, at
at the at IO last year, Google IO last
year, they showed this demo for the
text-to-image model, which is
you know, this is really easy prompt.
But, uh you know, lots of models
actually make mistakes on it. So, the
prompt is, do you go to next slide?
What is the square root of 81 * 2/3
squared plus, you know, blah blah blah.
And I think the answer is 39 to this
problem.
And so, you know, you pass that into the
model, and you ask the you ask the
Gemini diffusion to respond to that.
After one forward pass, these are the
tokens it's generated. So, one forward
pass through the model, it's starting to
respond. Now, since it's an iterative
refine the process, a one forward pass
is is not all it's going to do, but
after one forward pass it has this. So,
it has answer equals and then it said
60.
It's not correct, but that's what it's
guessing for now. And then it starts to
do the reasoning. So, a solution
calculate square root of 81 and so on.
After two forward passes, it's changed
60 to 49.
And it's gotten a little bit further
into the reasoning. So, it's gotten
like, you know, five steps into the
reasoning. 2 squared equals 4 and some
of the blue tokens are kind of still
going to change.
And then after three forward passes,
it's actually gotten all the way through
the reasoning.
So, it gets it gets and it gets the
answer correct at the end. 36 + 3 is
equal to 39. And it's gone back and
fixed the original response to say 39.
So, it's it had a mistake twice, 60 and
then 49, but once it finished the
reasoning, it was able to return back
and fix the mistake that it made at the
start. Now, it's going to do a couple
more forward passes in order to fix, you
know, some of these tokens that aren't
quite right in the text, but overall
that's basically the structure of the
output that it'll return.
And this is, you know, this is a a
property that text division models have.
This ability to do bidirectional
reasoning. So, to to not only see the
past, but also see the future that it's
going to utter. It's going to respond.
And also to use that information to do
self-correction. So, it made a mistake,
but it was able to, you know, had
another forward pass, it was able to go
through and fix that mistake.
At the time, you know, much, much bigger
models than the one we were serving made
a mistake for this problem. So, both
Chat GPT 4o, which was new at the time,
and Gemini 2.5 Flash, which was brand
new at the time, both made an error on
this on this exact problem. So, you give
them the exact same prompt and then they
would say, you know, remember the answer
is 39.
GPT 4o said 40.
That's the best guess it can do at that
one token. It went through the reasoning
and then it said 30 It did manage to
figure out it was 39 and said I made a
mistake. It's 39, not 40.
Uh Gemini 2.5 Flash also made a mistake,
said 42 and then it it actually just
stuck to its guns and never changed it
and said 36 + 3 is 42. So it like
incorporated the error into its
reasoning later. Uh and these are way
bigger models than the Gemini diffusion
models. So it's it's really is a
property a flaw of auto aggressive
models that the text diffusion models
don't have. Um and you know, you can fix
this with modern reasoning thinking
models. Uh but you know, then you're
just kind of punting the the problem
into something else, but
Anyway, okay. So that's that's that's
one advantage, which is bidirectional
reasoning self-correction. Another one
is what I I hinted at before, which is
dynamic computation. So you can you can
give the model more time at inference,
more forward passes, you get a bigger
budget, and it can just do better. It's
not exactly monotonic, but it is roughly
monotonic that the quality across every
eval basically just continues to go up
because it can it gets even if the even
if the solution is almost entirely clean
and correct, it gets to look at it
and see that it made a mistake and then
fix it. So you get this you get this
nice kind of curve where you always see
as the number of denoising steps such as
the forward passes go increases, you get
you can overall the the quality gets
higher. And these are just six coding
evals that we monitor internally.
On top of that, a slightly different
concept is it is the model can do
adaptive computation, which is that you
can allow the model, you train it in a
way to determine itself when it is
finished.
And then for easy responses, it can use
a little bit of compute and for harder
responses, it can take longer.
So here's just three examples from from
the Gemini diffusion model.
Which is what are the first 100 digits
of pi? This is actually 100 tokens. It
looks like a short response. This is
actually 100 tokens. And it only takes
four steps to do that. Because the model
it's an easy prompt. It's an easy
response because you've just memorized
the 100 digits of pi. You can just
output it. Whereas you know, for an auto
aggressive model in the same time would
have only done four tokens.
Um so that's a very easy one. Slightly
more challenging is to write a little
bit of code, so that takes you know, 18
forward passes
uh to generate FizzBuzz. And then some
something more complicated is explained
quantum mechanics in a single paragraph,
and that took 31 denoising steps. So, it
just took its time just for whatever
reason decided to spend longer on those
ones. And so, the model naturally gets
to decide I guess to determine when it's
going to finish and return the response.
And And typically, we see that harder
evals take more time. So, this is This
is a year ago now, so the evals are kind
of old school, but um
the you know, on the higher on the
harder end is GPQA Diamond, which for
this the model size we were targeting
was quite a hard eval, and that took a
long time for it to respond to those
ones.
Whereas on the other end are like MBPP,
which is mostly basic Python programs,
it was very it was very easy to you
know, took a very little time for it to
respond to these ones. And this is
entirely determined by the model itself.
Just easier problems, easier prompts, it
could respond to quickly, and harder
ones it decided itself to spend more
time reasoning.
Okay, so that's that's another property,
which is the a dynamic and adaptive
computation.
Lastly is the kind of fast in-place
editing. So, diffusion models in general
have this very nice property where you
can so, take an image
like in this example,
you know, cut something out of it or
whatever or give it a little prompt, and
it'll fill it in,
and you can use the context uh that that
you haven't cut out to fill in the the
piece you've cut out correctly. And so,
you you can use that for like clever
image editing, things like that.
Um And then because the reason it can do
that is because uh you know, it's not
autoregressive. There are autoregressive
image generators, right, which go left
to right, top to bottom like raster
order, generating pixels, you know, but
diffusion doesn't work like that. It'll
just see the entire image and then start
to denoise it. And because of that,
because it gets to see every pix- every
pixel gets to see every pixel, it can
fill in the missing information and and
do it in a way that's kind of consistent
with whatever prompt you're giving.
Uh Uh we can do something similar. So, I
have a couple of demos here.
Uh
Can you see that? Yeah, so this is just
some code and you say, "There is a bug
in this code. Can you fix it?" And it
just It'll just make the edit in the
correct place. Like, it won't you You
can barely see that, but it's just doing
a little fix here of the indices.
Uh and you can say things like, "Can you
add documentation?" And it'll go in.
It's not It's not just one by one
generating all the tokens. It's doing a
clever editing procedure to to actually
fill in the uh the correct edits here.
You can do that with, you know, more
general text. Like, you can take a story
and then say, "Add a middle paragraph."
And because it can see that the first
and the and this third paragraph, it can
fill in the paragraph in a way that's
consistent with the the rest of the
story, for instance. And this is just
in-place editing, basically.
Um okay. So, that's uh Those are some of
the advantages. Uh
don't have a lot of time.
Uh
the biggest advantage, like I mentioned,
is this low latency. And you know, we we
really lean into that. And uh I just
want to show you a couple of demos of
some of the things that people
internally have built to kind of show
what the advantage of low latency can
give you. So, it's not just the same
thing faster. It can really unlock some
new some really new applications. So, in
your own work, you're all AI engineers.
Uh it'd be interesting to see when when
the next diffusion model comes out from
our team
what the low latency could unlock. Uh
and kind of what new applications can be
built. So, here are just some demos. So,
this is Wikipedia. Let me just pause it,
actually. This is Wikipedia where
everything is generated on the fly, even
the HTML. So, this This is actually
being Oops. This is actually being
generated by the by the model on the
fly. So, that It's a web page with the
HTML and the text and everything being
generated on the fly. So, it looks like
regular Wikipedia. And when you click on
it, it's it's the the latency is low
enough that it can just fill in the page
as if it was a real Wikipedia page.
Um so, that's kind of uh Wikipedia
generated on the fly by a this is a very
low latency model. We have a similar
thing where we did it for Reddit.
So, now all the responses to your posts
will be by bots. They weren't already.
Um
and it's generating fake comments. Not
the So,
uh the Gemini diffusion model was not an
image generating model. So, this demo
links in the which was our startup
state-of-the-art image generator model
at the time, which I think was Juno. Was
it was before Nano Banana. So, it is the
two of these models working together to
fill in the web page. So, it's the image
generation model is a little slower. Um
but you can see that it's like, you
know,
you can you can
invent any Reddit you want, sharks in
this case, and it'll generate the page
with the text. The images follow a
minute a minute later, and then you can
interact with this website as if it was
a real website with, you know, real
users and so on. Just being entire All
the comments, all the images, all the
HTML, everything is being generated
entirely on the fly here. This is being
generated by the model.
Um I love this one. This is my favorite
one.
This is an operating system also being
entirely generated on the fly. So, every
click here is generating the next page
of the operating system. So, it looks
like a real operating system, but it's
all being generated by the model on the
fly responding to every click. So, every
time you enter like the readme, it
generates the text, but it also
generates, you know, the the web pages
you can do, you know, go back to the
desktop and and so on.
I think this
Yeah, okay. Um and then this is a this
is a demo from someone on Twitter who
used the
who used the Gemini diffusion API
uh or sorry, not the API, the web page
to do some
live coding with his voice. So, I I
really like this one.
>> Create a to-do app.
Add 10 random to-dos.
Allow to-dos to have a completed state.
Mark four random to-dos as completed.
Allow me to sort to-do's by name and by
state.
All right, let's see if this works. Sort
by name, sort by state. Testing, enter,
was added to the bottom. We'll try
deleting a few. Add one. Everything's
working. Please convert this to dark
mode.
And this was literally 15 seconds of
work.
>> Okay, so that was uh yeah, that was
someone outside of our team so he he
could say that.
Uh yeah, but five coding by voice but
but just in general I think that, you
know, low latency models can really
unlock some new experiences uh for users
and new products. And so we're excited
to see what people will do when the next
generation comes out. Okay, and on that
note, thank you very much.
>> [applause]
>> Questions? Yeah?
>> Yeah, yeah. So yeah, we use all the same
data. Yeah. I mean, the algorithms have
to change a bit but we use all the same
data. Yeah.
You can distill them, yeah. Yeah,
they're I'm not sure if there are any
published ones.
>> [laughter]
>> I don't think so. Maybe they're selling
externally but
There's a
Yeah, so we're going to release
something soon. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
Uh
yeah, so there's a the bigger models
tend to require less steps
for the same output. So, they kind of
you know, even if the model is getting
bigger and the flops per forward pass
are getting bigger, they tend to
reduce the
the forward passes they need.
So, it's kind of a
you kind of have some sort of a
diminishing cost of serving even the
biggest models. Yeah.
>> So, the next question, do you
how do you
price the
price of the structure doesn't matter
for the diffusion
>> Uh I don't know. We haven't got to that
yet. I'm a research scientist.
Uh
Yeah.
>> How do you define the size of the answer
because for
>> Yeah.
>> you expect that I have this image and I
have the output
>> Yeah.
>> frame. How do you do that in
>> Mhm.
>> coding or text?
>> So, there's a there's a there's a few
different ways. The easiest way is to
just fix some some window length and
then just iterate on that. So, it's like
auto aggressive, block-wise auto
aggressive. It's kind of the standard
way to do it. But, you can have like a a
head that will predict the length of the
response and stuff like that if you
wanted. Yeah.
>> Yeah, but you have to fix the outcome in
order to let the diffusion model
>> No, it still can generate unlimited
texts texts, but it's just if you fix a
window length
then it just does that window length
auto aggressively if it needs to
generate like many many windows of text.
Yeah.
>> I might have already mentioned this, but
when you gave that example of the
denoising steps being different ranges
with different, you know, uh
>> Yeah.
>> Could you ahead of time set like a a
limit on the denoising steps that you
that you require for a problem so you
can have
>> Yeah.
>> almost just understand what your latency
is going to be ahead of time?
>> Mhm.
Yeah, yeah, these are all with a limit,
but they just finish as with earlier
than the limit. Yeah.
>> If you if you had multiple windows like
you just said going through, can can
they then go back and attempt to
previous windows? Is that kind of as the
window goes is it
>> It's Yeah, it's it's I mean that that
you could potentially, but for for us we
just set it in stone and continue. Yeah.
Yeah.
Other questions here?
Yeah, yeah, that's how it works. Yeah.
Oh no, so it's prefill is the same. It's
just so you've got some context and you
pre you prefill.
Uh and then after that the generation
step is typically in blocks of some
fixed size, like 512 or 1,000 or 32 or
whatever you want. And then that's auto
aggressive.
Yeah.
So you can do that. Um the easiest way
to do it is to just have like a logits
at the top. Just vanilla prediction head
at the top.
Well, it So this is like this is all
like discrete diffusion, right? So it's
always tokens in tokens out. Like if I
show you the
For every step, yeah.
So if I go back here, it's always like a
discrete corruption process.
And then you fill in a discrete token
back in. So it's always So you're always
in a discrete space.
But you can do it in latent spaces, but
and people have done that, but most of
the most of the text diffusion models in
literature is discrete diffusion today.
Yeah.
There might be one day.
>> I think for now they have different use
cases. So, you know, if you think about
what a low latency
model provides, that's like that's worse
throughput. So, what's that trade-off
is on-device applications. So, we are in
a couple of on-device applications
already.
Um and within like the Alphabet
ecosystem. So, robotics, things like
that, where you want to run a a model on
the device itself. So, your phone or a
robot or whatever. And then you but you
want it to be low latency and you're not
batching with thousands of other queries
like Gemini being served in the service
side. So,
you want the lowest latency model.
Quality isn't really any They're the
same quality basically.
So, then you may as well pick the low
latency one cuz you don't have the
throughput concerns.
>> What do you mean like
in the in the future like can we get
quality up to the bar with with the
current black box models?
>> I Quality isn't the concern, it's the
throughput uh for serving in a big batch
setting. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
>> So, currently you are getting more or
less the same quality of frontier models
in your research?
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> So, what about reasoning tasks? Because
we
we can really verify what we want.
>> Sorry?
>> What what about reasoning tasks? Because
we we can really verify what we want.
Something like this.
>> Yeah, yeah. Yeah, you can do RL. Yeah.
You just need to change the algorithm,
you know, but you can still do it.
Yeah.
>> Is there much scope for combining
diffusion with autoregressive text
models?
>> Yeah, you can do that. Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Can you like initialize with a smaller
model so you don't have to start from
noise so you can have to do less steps?
>> Um
the problem with that is if you train it
with noise, it expects noise. You'd have
to train it with the small model.
As you like the output and that just
adds complexity. So, we don't usually do
that.
Yeah.
Um
Well, not from not from our team, but
there are there's a bunch of literature
out there, yeah.
Yeah.
You get the idea, I think. Yeah.
Any other questions? There's a lot of
questions.
Gone through them all. That's good.
Oh, one more. Okay.
Um
I don't know.
I don't think we've tried to do that.
>> [laughter]
>> Probably would work. It would probably
do something. Yeah.
Cool. Okay. Thanks, everybody.
>> [applause]
[music]